um i wonder if we could make a start
please um
what i'd like what i'd um well firstly
probably to follow a good process can i
just
firstly ask as we move into the do you
have any apologies
so tim is not here normally would be is
he going to join us by zooming maybe he
will we won't take him on the stage
we'll see where we stand on that
in relationship to it though i do want
to ask just for a minute i want to raise
under um
uh the agenda are people under time
pressure today
quite a full agenda always always always
alan i appreciate that okay we'll come
back to that
um there are no apologies at this stage
um we will move on i have no
vindication at this stage of
any public forum
um and then i'd like to move to uh
changes to the public agenda
sorry to the agenda we have currently
under
the public excluded agenda the receipt
of the independent review of
arrangements
around uh electronic access and
um
uh i would uh from the chair
um uh
uh wish to
oh for a sec
as a major leader sorry
sorry it's that's a that's a good point
let me um uh we we have the report
and i'd like to propose that rather than
hear it in public excluded that we
actually
receive it and
debate it in public
in other words that we do two things we
receive it as a late item because
obviously it was only finalized and sent
to you on monday number one
and number two that we receive
and debate and deal with the report
actually in public
so i will move from the chair that we we
deal with that do i have a second to
please thank you nobby
is there any discussion on the motion
there being none i'll put it all those
in favor please say aye
those against
it's carried
i'd also just like to acknowledge
that over the weekend nobby sent me
today alex bobby sent me um uh an email
from one of our ratepayers mr tribe
um who did actually
look at that item as we had it listed on
public excluded and
on my good advice sorry on advice to me
i quite agree that we had uh tried to
use the wrong
uh or incorrect section to have it in
public excluded so nobby thank you for
forwarding that and thank you to mr
tribe that he actually put it out a
mistake in our administration
and uh but but the fact that we have
moved us to public actually removes the
issue
that he raised so i think claire is
going to respond to mr tribe
formally just to indicate that we
acknowledge his his comment
right um
that being the case um i wonder if i
could then move please to
declarations of interests
do we have any matter here that needs to
be uh on the agenda that we you need to
raise any matters of interest over
being none um
i would like to then move to um
[Music]
sorry i need to check here clear the
public excluded do we deal with that now
um in terms of where it sits in the
agenda i've always struggled with this
one no no no no we don't later thank you
that's good it's just where it sits
thank you can we move please to item
four which is the
minutes and we have two sets of minutes
here we have both the ordinary meeting
we had on the 24th
of august and we also have the
emergency meeting which we received the
six-month
review update by mr thompson on the 6th
of september
i would move from the chair that we
accept those as a true and correct
record is there any matters of
correction
uh or update that people need uh to to
raise with these matters
they've been none they'll put the motion
uh
and thank you rangi uh all those in
favor please say aye
those against it's carried thank you
very much
um
you then please move to item five oh
sorry i realized again
thinking about this this move to public
public
forum public forum of the uh the report
on
that we're receiving i propose to have
it at the end of the agenda we will go
through the established agenda
um which which public agenda which will
include
the verbal update from michael then we
will deal with the stage with
the report that we've moved into public
right now that i've got myself hopefully
could
the
it or in the right way i'd like to move
we've dealt with item five as well can
we no we haven't just we have can we
please move to item six which is working
on working together update and i think
we've got jane on board thank you jane
good morning very king good morning
everybody
would you like me to just speak to this
briefly
yes please jane that would be very
helpful yeah um look just a a
a few
things to note though working on working
together reporting has got a bit out of
sync
partly because of code
partly because of the late delivery of
the six month review
so in effect this report is rather
outdated
and more for the record than anything
else
um the things i'd like to note is that
work is already underway in implementing
and what the next steps should be
in terms of the thompson report i think
that's noted in this report
in fact the governance group meets on
next wednesday
the agenda will be out on friday and
that contains a plan to implement
the suggested next steps
um i would like to note a couple of
things about this report
recommendation for the risk register is
way out of date and in fact you'll see a
different picture
when the the governance group reports
back to the next
council meeting
and the second thing to note is the
budget because i know that risk and
insurance are
always interested in the budget
um we are well within budget
but we will probably i suggest um take
the opportunity to recast what goes
where along with the new
suggested plan going forward so i think
that's all i'd like to say bruce and
happy to take any questions thank you
jane appreciate it do you have any
questions for jane um or any comments
about the report that people like to
make
i think you've probably summed it up
jane that actually it's come it's come
um
in a timing cycle where actually the
next report will be a substantial
upgrade on the basis of the report so i
appreciate that you're swinging
um just looking at the nice colored
charts thing
um item item six
which is the lacking lack of willingness
by council to take
action based in one word on
advice from this project now it's got
the impact as being medium
um i i think the impact of this is
actually
critical it's quite high
that if it if if um
if the willingness is not there then
it's
it's gone
it's a non-event
and we've seen a couple of recent
examples where
that willingness is not there um
so i just want to comment on that where
does where does that sit
have we got the right the right waiting
on that
well firstly the the impact is medium
but at the moment the post the
post-mitigation likelihood is high rangi
so we are we are on this risk one
identifying that is a significant issue
clear sorry jane i'm conscious that
you've said that the report will look
quite different i
don't want to anticipate your report but
i wonder whether you might have a
comment on this one at the situation
this time please
yes the report this risk register looks
quite different and i'm quickly trying
to go to what it looks like now but from
memory
um we're just down to about two risks
that we need to worry about
if i can
just get into
this bit here i can tell you what it
looks like
now
bear with me
um
sorry counselor
jane if it's too hard i'm very happy
that we we take my advice that you you
think it's changing
it's probably um
a waste of
the committee's time for me to look up
and tell you exactly what it's looking
like now because you may want to debate
it
but it has changed
from what we've got now for the better
or for the worse
i wouldn't be for the worse because
we've got a good report so it'll be
jane's report that's right that's right
that's a that's uh that's that's
comforting to know
um
that's always going to be a matter i
suspect
it's going to be on the on the uh the
list while we are undergoing the working
on working together programs so i
appreciate that you've actually raised
it uh and that we need to keep our eye
on it because it goes to the foundation
of what we are trying to achieve here
in which i think we can acknowledge that
the six month review said that on the
whole we are we are
heading in the right direction uh if not
actually having achieved a lot
thank you for that ranging is there any
other questions people are raised here
can i just make a point that i i hear
what ring is saying but if we look at
the word
counselling and distinguish it from
counsellors
council has taken action
so from from that perspective um i think
the report is accurate yes
yeah thank you
i thought council is council laws in the
definition
uh let's not get too worried about that
guys can be honest
there is a very interesting semantic
point here and and i actually think
they're both they're both quite good
points to bake so
um i'd like to suggest we move on
i i wanted to raise a few points in
regarding the
ken patterson report
and the buchanan report
that doesn't come up till the end of the
meeting thank you sir tim um
prior to your coming we have we have uh
passed the motion
that in the public section of the agenda
we will deal with
the report on to
access
and that will be done as item i think
it's like effectively item 13 now on the
public agenda
right can we move to the recommendations
please
on jane's uh report working on working
together update
uh there um there's somebody prepared to
move those for me please
yes thank you rangy thank you bex
is any discussion on the motion
or motions i should say
being none i'll put them all those in
favor please say aye hi those against
it's carrie thank you very much
if we could then move to
item six which is the interim uh
internal audit program update um peter i
suspect we need to find a place for you
i can see at the back that you've got a
microphone that's good i'll pass it over
to you please uh morning mr chair
council as you wish it um i'll take the
report as being red and just like to
note that there's been additional seven
actions completed since the august
report
um so we're trending down with the
remaining actions outstanding which is
um positive
um
deloitte are also conducting two reviews
at the moment for sensitive expenditure
and payroll we expect those reports in
october which will be reported to the
december committee meeting
mr chair brilliant thank you very much
if there's any questions yes have any
questions for peter at the stage
just have a couple peter
sorry mate um uh and firstly uh
appreciate the the the closure
of items
i guess the the the critical thing i'd
like to know is actually have we got any
really significant
recommendations that are outstanding um
uh probably using the camera i went
straight to the caching and petty cash
um for which we've closed five but if
the 15 that are open uh are big issues
um we've got a bigger problem so i'm
just trying to understand if you give us
a sense of where that's at uh the main
ones outstanding are in accounts payable
but with the introduction of the
procurement framework and policy this
will actually clear up a number of those
accounts payable especially the uh the
12 high
high risk items right okay thank you
ross i think you had a question did you
it was more about the broader picture of
the whole internal audit program and
that
um the time frame for completion and
then i presume a rolling
rolling check of particular items and
also are we using internal resource or
as well or are we relying solely on
deloitte
better perhaps you can explain to me
you're explaining to the group the
program and and actually the
arrangements you've got for internal
audit as it stands please um we have a
engagement for three years with deloitte
to work through the internal audit
program i'm waiting for an update from
them on the following two years of the
program we also have an internal order
that does um
building control authority and
environmental health audits on our
behalf for accreditation purposes as
well as additional audits i.e for animal
care facility or any other autistic uh
arizona
if you're there
no it's good that's good yeah yeah
um
and look perhaps just to reflect and i'm
trying to think whether we have
occasionally annually we should actually
see indeed what is the internal program
plan whether it's both internal or
external um so peter perhaps if you uh
later might want to just remind us when
we might see that i think ross that's
probably if i can read into your
question a valuable point for us to be
aware of i'm sure we've seen it so
no worries any other questions
there being none i'd like to look at the
moves the recommendations which is that
which is that we um
note the interim report from peter and
also that seven uh actions have been
completed which is great do i have a
mover for that motion please thank you
ross
uh thank you darren
i'll put the motion then please all
those in favor please say aye
[Music]
those against it's carrie thank you very
much
thank you thanks peter appreciate the
time
um project management office status
update here's a good favorite one for a
risk committee at this
well actually probably this year
actually of all things so uh lee i think
we met you last time by my career online
by way of uh videos so welcome
uh physically and uh
here as well thank you
we're in your hands
morning all um just like to run through
the report um obviously i've taken it
that's been read
and um i'll just pop through the
program
uh project by project if that's okay
um anderson house we're progressing with
that well uh we're just in the contract
phase of that so um that's on track and
we're quite comfortable where we are
with that one
the healthy house program
is running well in the sense that uh by
the time of the next risk and all that i
think we should be complete
and so that's uh that's going well
and the revision or reimagining phase of
the
museum
is also tracking quite well
and that's uh we appointed all our
consultants for that and we're into
workshops uh with the different groups
so that's uh that's also tracking uh
very well
the office refurbishment
i've actually taken a bit of time just
to have a look at that and sort of um do
a bit discovery myself on on that one
and i've sort of tweaked the procurement
plan for that um so just we've sort of
re-rephased that a little bit so it's
slowed down a couple of weeks and that's
just to give me give myself some time
just to um
get up to speed with it
so we've reforecast that one slightly
the city center streets you would have
seen
um we're now boots on the ground which
is
which is excellent
and um when construction's underway
i'm sure we'll i'm sure there'll be some
questions on that a bit later
the three waters renewals that's a bit
of an ongoing
program of work which is tracking um not
too bad
the banks on water main is probably
one of the ones we've got a bit of a
bit of an issue with and we're working
we're working through that at the moment
and i'm sure there'll be some questions
on that a bit later um design we're
really pushing normal design to remove a
lot of risk here on that particular
project
the stock bank
again tracking tracking reasonably well
and
we're looking at still looking at
construction hopefully starting in
november
that sort of concludes the
the wart tower obviously is uh is closed
so we won't go into that too much
thank you for that lee our test you're
here there's anything you need to add to
this in terms of sort of systems process
or risks
no no everything is going well then i'm
handed over from uh from me to him so
i'm just tidying up a couple of loose
ends with lee and thought if there's any
um
i suspect rang you through your
committee that you do deal directly with
these issues um what i'm wanting to
reflect here our role is to make certain
systems and processes and the overall
control
is in place
so i'm not wanting to relitigate
necessarily individual
projects unless there are unless there
are matters that should be of a risk and
assurance nature that we should have so
it's a very good report but i'm very
keen to know that we we keep ourselves
at that high level this because rangi i
presume you've done this on a
line-by-line basis correct at your
committee
pipe pipe
okay so that's good so i'm just reminded
that we're here to deal particularly
with with the broader issues so i'm keen
that we keep it at that level are there
questions for lee or tess at the stage
guys oh i killed it because
i'm sorry about that let's make it
that's made it a bit quicker
[Laughter]
um can i just sorry
if the risk at the risk then that i have
i have killed it gotta ask a couple
questions please lee and tess if that's
okay absolutely um uh and i'm just
interested in the in the three waters
renewal
in terms of in terms of uh a committee
uh risk committee we often relate
dollars to the total forecast for the
year the budget because that's that's
the big strategic issue that we all face
um and and when looking at the diagram i
was trying to work out actually what are
the milestones what gives me the comfort
that the renewal program is on track and
going well
um because when i looked at the diagram
it was just one it's construction
um
but i i wonder if we have a sense as to
whether that renewal program which is as
which is of equal importance to all the
vertical builds we we have are we on
track is this in the right place
i think
for a tracking mechanism i think you're
right in the sense of costs you know
cost uh forecasted and cost spent and
committed it's probably the
a very high level way of pulse checking
to see where where that's at
um
if that's helpful in answering that yeah
at this moment you're comfortable with
the renewal programs what i'm trying to
say
okay sweet um and look there are two
reds there on and i'm looking here at
page 28 to 77.
um there are two reds there um i think
you've said you're comfortable in any
sense we have a plan to address those
two reds yeah yep sweet okay that's good
any other questions folk would like to
raise
right if we move then please to um
uh um
actually no sorry there was one other
one sorry if you looked at i was
interested in the three waters which is
relevant given we've got demands
in relationship to uh
central government funding
and the dependencies were in red
which says uh we're tracking
uh but reliance on contractors to
perform what is the market like for the
thing
yeah look we're tracking that one as red
because we are on a shared panel with
south and district council and it is
just a question of being able to manage
those resources across both
um councils so it's it's absolutely on
on the list for us as a critical item we
don't have the resources we can't
deliver the program and so that's why
we're still showing it as read we are
doing a lot of program work with both
councils are working together um and
hopefully in the next reporting period
that will de-escalate
i just wanted to make a comment just
around that resourcing on the panel it's
an interesting one because we're quite
constantly going back to the panel and
asking them are they comfortable that
they have the resources to meet the
program
to this stage we're constantly getting a
yes yes we do
but again we're just taking a little bit
of that conservative approach to that
one because we we are concerned that
they may be over promising um so we need
to keep a really tight eye on that one
i'm encouraged by the um and nuclear
interest obviously but i'm encouraged by
the connection with southern district
because i presume in that way
essentially we don't get ourselves into
a bidding war south africa
which makes a lot of sense
and yet hopefully the total contractor
market also benefits from the approach
i'm i'm thrilled by that that makes
sense
okay some other questions um given i've
done a lot i've done all the questioning
i should probably move from the chair
that we've received the project
management office latest report thank
you lady thank you tess um uh do i have
a second to please oh secondly
oh uh is there any discussion on the
motion
being none i'll put the motion please
all those in favor please say aye
those against it's kerry brilliant thank
you
move to item nine uh really important
and and very interesting uh
policy development um our procurement
policy and uh
i'd appreciate it
take it nick you're gonna lead off
thank you chuck moreno councillors um so
this this report is bringing back the
procurement policy um now that it has
been workshop by councillors and
um internal manager discussions for
adoption for engagement
i will just note that the date on the
report is wrong so apologies for that it
is the correct report
somehow that managed to slip through the
net
um
so probably i'll just touch briefly i'll
take the report as read but i'll touch
briefly on the engagement plan so the
proposal is really to focus um
in on two main groups the first one is
the supplier market themselves so we've
done some work reaching out already to
suppliers
and we will run a webinar for them a q a
session with nick and with the
procurement team so that they can ask
any questions and we can elevate any
potential issues that may be
around the implementation of the policy
and then secondly we will make the
policy available to the wider public
which
we anticipate the interest there might
be more around the social procurement
options that the policy allows for
um and so we will gather feedback from
those two groups and um
and then bring a report back to this
committee
thanks rianna appreciate that um and i
think uh i certainly compliment you on
the
voluntary um consultation process that
you're going through which is do we have
questions
uh or points that you the committee
would like to make with uh rihanna
please thank you alex um thank you mr
chair um i
um i mean we had a really comprehensive
um workshop around this and you know
talked about um options before we had
gone through a procurement process that
um when our previous um
framework didn't really allow for so i'm
really happy to see the inclusion um of
quite a few parameters that we didn't
have before including the social and
like really defining what it means to be
economical and um cultural also the
environmental weighting and our
procurement process so i would be um
more than happy to approve and endorse
all three recommendations and also
noting that we're going out for a
voluntary consultation on this or
engagement sorry not consultation um
and that is excellent for the local
community to be able to engage with us
in that manner especially when they're
going to be pitching for those
themselves thanks alex
effectively you're saying you're going
to move the motion if that's the case
but i have a second
thank you vicks is any other any other
more
comments either on the motion or indeed
on the paper that people like to race
i have a couple actually that's okay i'm
gonna get my questions in um um i
look it's important um and i would want
to perhaps just remind councillors of
this that under b in the pro we are
we are asserting that we will be ethical
and fair in our treatment in the market
and i think we are we are saying that we
will hold ourselves to a high standard
um uh and it's important i think to
remember that sgs we enter into the
procurement process is that we will have
[Music]
basically everything that we do so um i
happen to note that but look just just a
couple questions um random when i looked
at three governments and approvals and i
don't want to sort of be
uh too all over the place just remind me
about supply panels they come in over a
hundred thousand dollars they don't they
don't operate at a lower level
i thought the supplier panels might have
actually operated for a lower level of
contract
um
with the hundred thousand what we're
basically saying is
you do have to use panels or go out to
the market
under 100 000 you can get
you can process more towards uh
three quotes or single quote which can
involve a panel or may not involve a
panel but it's more open so
got that thank you nick appreciate that
so it's more optional get up and i and
for over um and the only thing i also
noticed then was on the next page was
with probity advice
and a probability auditor would be for
um it would be
optional i think i've got yes maybe
appointed for and it would be projects
over five million
uh and not necessarily ones under or do
we still reserve the right if there was
something sensitive under five million
that we might have a priority audit
would that be right that's correct
correct good okay that's great so i'd be
keen to know um and a minor point um
under
under the the stages um uh 1.1 this is
on page
uh what a secret i can find it on my
thing 41 to 77
um i think the i note the important at
the identify council and community needs
you're actually starting to identify
some of the design principles and
planning principles you'll bring into
your project so diversity disability
business blah blah blah and you've got
reducing carbon footprint i wondered
whether whether there was also a case
for addressing climate change in the
sense of the effects that it may have on
our facilities and that we would allow
for those not just
not just the the good merit of reducing
our carbon footprint um but actually
also the effects of of of climate change
who knows might be more regular flooding
blah blah blah and does that affect
floor heights and all that sort of drama
that would be my questions nobby i think
if you have you got uh points yeah just
just one for nick um
when we had the workshop i noticed there
was a provision
in the paper that was initially
presented that doesn't seem to be here
so if you can help me i've lost it there
was a provision in on page 37
we'll talk about the different levels of
criteria against how much the contracts
are worth and there was one there in
fine print that said temporary contracts
could be extended
where there was no increase to the value
of the contract
without going to the marketplace now
that seems to have been lost in this
and i use that because we've recently
used it to extend the
recycling contract with sda under that
principle so has it been moved somewhere
else have i missed it
so the provision basically said if we
had a temporary contract in place and
wish to extend it
and it didn't involve an increase in the
financial cost of that contract it could
go
to a
gmo
group manager for approval without going
to the marketplace and there was no
value against that
so that seems to have gone
i
need to go back to the notes but the
general intent is when contracts come up
before renewal they will be put out to
the open market some will be extended if
we don't have the resources to go
immediately out to the market
and with the larger value ones they will
come
through the council so i'd need to
probably double click the comment you
want i'd like to hear back on that
because we've recently extended a
contract as you'll be aware a
significant contract with a significant
value
and the period that we extended to is
also significant
and that was done under that provision
that provisions now gone
and so i'd like to think that was just
an oversight and that that hasn't been
removed because that boxes in
um some of the contracts we've got
okay look nobody i think um we've got
the benefit this comes back to us sure
okay so i'm very grateful that you've
raised it but i think i think if we just
recognize
what we've ran in nick time to as they
go through the consultation process to
uh pick up on on uh if and how that may
may not be addressed alex did you have
another point please it was it was more
just on that line of thinking and um it
may be a silly question but
if we have this policy um
and a situation arises where that could
be extraordinary like perhaps to what
council clark is referencing
if we adopt this policy does that
preclude us from making a decision that
is outside of the scope of the policy
provided we have
a different lay of the land in a
different circumstance perhaps it's
extraordinary or
emergency
the policy does have fake claws or
sexual which allows the co
or a tm with the relevant delegations to
operate outside the policy
what the aim of the policy is as we
state it is to probably cover 95 of the
transactions there will always be
exceptions and that's why we put that
specific clause in
in the policy
thank you nick
yes sorry
thank you through yourself chair um just
wanted to add into there and it does
respond back to both questions that have
been asked
the
delegation in relation to renewal and
extensions is part of our appendix ii
um which refers to um
delegation it must be within delegation
in relation to that so it can go through
your gm process but of course if it
needs delegation above that from an
extension a contract then it needs to go
through the council channel as well from
that perspective so it is possible from
that respect for those extensions and it
is um the same from those um
exceptions etcetera as well
thanks there uh mike is nobby just just
as an addition to what alex has just
said and what nick responded to
um
it raises some concerns with me that we
have
a set of policy going out for public
consultation which
um
gives the community some sort of
parameters on how we'll deal with our
procurement which is big dollars and so
we have a lot of purchasing power in the
community
but then we have potentially a five
percent
um
provision that might we might be able to
scoot round it a little bit
um that we have some other criteria in
the back back room as it were that says
that we can actually
put this to a side now
we've all been around long enough to
know what happened with the recycling
tender last time it was an absolute mess
for us and i don't want somebody to come
back and bite me in the rear end by
saying well you know you've got this
policy here you publicly consult on it
but then you've got a very large
contract that goes around that
so i just need to have some certainty
around that and so be helpful to have
that come back thank you and nobby i
would remind that's why i actually
pointed out right start my first comment
was we are committing ourselves and
writing you to ethical and fair
treatment sure
so um you know i
i think you use 95 percent as a as a
just a number
i wouldn't i wouldn't want to suggest
that all of a sudden we're just going to
um through this willy-nilly allow five
percent the reality of it is the
principle is that we are fair and
ethical fair and ethical
and that is to the market
so that would have to be a primary
principle that any decision maker within
council would take on board with them as
they as they dealt with this policy so
um look good point thank you michael
thank you navi nick that's uh that's a
key part to think through as part of
what what's consorted i appreciate that
any other questions or comments for
funic or all around at the stage
that being the case to none i have alex
moving in beck seconding
and it's to do deal with all three which
is that we receive we
note the engagement plan
and uh that we we essentially are
adopting the draft procurement policy
for that engagement process
uh and i think it's fair to say we've
heard the comment you've heard the
comments from us about the various parts
which you may want to consider as you
finalize
consultation
i'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
those against
it's carrie thank you very much thank
you
thank you appreciate your work on that
nick and around and this is uh it's a
highly
important area for the sector as a whole
at the moment
i think we're moving then to the
long-term plan review um i suggest randy
you're probably staying there i suspect
um if you could
take us through your paper please i'd
appreciate that
thank you chair so yes this report deals
with um the review of the long term plan
and so outlines how that review was
undertaken um key findings of the review
and then some of the learnings that will
be taken forward in terms of the
delivery and preparation for the
delivery of the
2024-2034 long-term plan
um so i won't go into the report in too
much detail but just to note that
it was really
good to see the
engagement of the counsellors
and various members of the staff who
were involved in the process and that a
wide level of feedback will help to
inform and deliver a successful
long-term plan next time around i think
broadly the feelings about this
long-term plan was that it was a process
that was well delivered under difficult
circumstances that the engagement with
the process was high
and that we ended up with a fairly
strong result in terms of the plan that
came out at the other end
there are of course some areas where we
will definitely be able to improve for
next time going into the long term plan
right at the beginning of the process it
was determined at that time that we
would take an iterative approach
to the long-term plan improvement given
the scale of what was needed to be done
when we um started in february um last
year
um so some of that will continue um and
that is in that diagram which um
i'm not sure what page it's on i think
it's on page 47 which shows some of
those elements of improvement that will
be built into the cycle for the next
time around so some of that is around
asset condition data
the work of the climate change working
group which has commenced and will soon
be bringing a report to cancel
um issues around improving the
performance framework some of the
customer research
um etc elements of that type
um
the only other thing that i will mention
is that
some of this report covers
a document produced by simon markham who
is a strategy manager of many years
experience at another council
who reviewed the process for determining
um investment in strategic projects and
that was as part of the governance work
stream so that report is provided here
for completeness but just as jane
mentioned earlier that work stream was
delayed by covert um and so the working
group actually only discussed that
report with simon yesterday so there may
be something that members of that
working group want to say at this point
about that report
lindsey that's your group is that right
uh yesterday we did meet yesterday for
the first time in a long time and
had the opportunity to hear from simon
on zoom about his report and its
recommendations
the upshot of all of that is that we
agreed at the working group yesterday
that the framework itself would be the
product of the work that rhiannon has
done and is progressing through risk and
assurance and the offering from the
working group would be a suite of
guidance notes to support that
framework and my task as a consequence
of the decisions yesterday is to recast
one of the papers that they considered
in a form that can be signed off by the
working group which we may potentially
do
electronically
and then come through to pgg and the
council and that will complete
the working groups task and bring
together
the
offering i suppose rhiannon's work plus
the
the contribution that the working group
has made and we should be able to sign
that all off by
the end of
november depending on meeting sequence
thank you that's good
right thank you for that lindsay thank
you rhiannon are the other questions
points that uh members would like to
make
at the stage please
there are none well she was getting my
questions in sorry random
um can i look can we just stop protect
can we all go to
page
what is it it's the first page 45-77
now how do we celebrate around this
place
how do we guys we're gonna we're gonna
say well done can we say what under
annan she's gonna present at the taitura
conference and is it november
now let's remember taitu ara or solgam
is based around promoting good practice
best practice
and the fact is they have asked
invercargill to present
isn't that good
so the work that you are doing
is being shared elsewhere around the
country
are you going to celebrate there i don't
know how but i suggest that you do
and in fact i'd love it to be noted in
the minutes
that actually we congratulate
ariana in particular and the fact that
that this will be shown
at uh at um uh for all its good
strengths
uh and debated at thai toyota in as i
think it is november so um in your
southern reserve can i suggest that you
are happy you smile and you say well i'm
rhiannon right at the stage thanks
patricia it's a good christchurch
presence you know
okay so what um thank you and appreciate
that
i do think it's well done to everyone
well good for being humble too but thank
you think that's really really good now
i've got now got my questions so well
done
um can i just say well done on the
diagram
um i think that's that's
probably because i read diagrams better
than i read words um i actually found
this
really helpful and and i take on board
your point
about the need for planning to be
continuous
and actually i just want to reflect an
important point here i don't know why
october 2022 is in green
on your diagram other than of course
it's the next local body elections
and this reflects the importance of us
capturing indeed the work that you have
done now with people like simon lindsay
your strategic uh
uh working party
because we need to build on our
corporate understanding and knowledge as
we go forward so that leads me then to
to probably
uh really my only question um
uh rhiannon and that is if i understand
it correctly i'm looking at page 52 of
77
uh there is
a preparation of an improvement
plan
i
take it that that's what that diagram is
effectively showing
i guess i'm really asking the question
should we include that in our resolution
because i don't see it recognized there
and i think it's important
that we recognize that we endorse
the preparation and adherence to a
improvement plan
i'm open to your suggestions on that and
i don't have to we don't have to we
don't want to but i'm just interested in
diabetes um
i certainly have no problem with that i
just want to clarify you're talking
about the diagram because it's page 47
on mine is it is it that one that you're
talking about yes i'm more than happy
for a recommendation noting that there
is an improvement plan
in place good
uh look that's felt fine i i i would
like to that we note that if i'm really
should be talking to my members that we
note that in under four
because i think it's important that we
recognise we have a plan which we should
monitor
developments against
in future meetings which is really
superb
okay the other questions people like to
raise no
can we then just move to the uh the
recommendations please and they are
fulsome as you might expect with uh such
a good point we note the key findings we
note um the report
into the prioritization of strategic
projects
as part of the long-term plan received
from simon markham
and we endorse the recommendations
that underpin
the plan which is we recognise
continuous planning we refined the
strategic project decision making
framework that was a very interesting
framework well done we utilized the
decision making framework
within strategic decision making process
supporting ongoing alignment with a
long-term plan sorry i think that was a
really good point you made that actually
it's not just the long-term plan this
all relates what's actually for our
decision making full stop
we recognize the projects are stronger
when business cases are developed
and i would like to suggest
uh e
um uh that we acknowledge
there is uh an uh improvement plan in
place
um which will be monitored
that may seem a wee bit uh
week but i'd just like to get it in fact
that we need to monitor that as an
improvement plan
i'm glad to see your talking's as good
as mine thank you
from time to time
from time to time
uh well when monitored from time to time
by this community by this committee yes
yes thank you
that makes it better doesn't it okay
um we note that the ltp project team
will continue which is uh
great
um and actually appreciate the second
part of that which is an opportunity for
the council to continue to guide the
process
um and we note the
issue identified as key focus area for
the next long-term plan isn't it crazy
we're already talking about that
sorry excuse me chair i think you're
just missing the word plan from that
resolution
oh the improvement plan sorry thank you
very much
uh look given i'm i'm going to suggest
that we take that as a um uh as without
there i sat through formal amendment i
will from the chair put the motion that
we
that we move and
these motions do i have a second please
thank you darren
is there any discussion on the motions
there being none i'll put them all one
to six
including um the new e as i think we've
now got got up on the board thank you
very much all those in favor please say
aye
those against
it's carrie thank you
right can we move please then look at
that 20 22 23 annual plan delivery we're
into thinking annual plans already
um and that's tremendous random again
you're still there thank you you're in
the hot seat
um thank you again chase so the annual
plan delivery this report is really to
provide the risk insurance committee
with an overview of where things are at
in preparation for the annual plan um
the approach from a financial
perspective will be that we are using
year two as the base budget this is not
a total reforecast
[Music]
there are a number of projects where of
course timelines and budgets are
shifting slightly
so the elt has been fully briefed on
those especially those within the
capital space that may have a larger
impact at this point in time we are
thinking it is likely we will need to
consult on this annual plan probably as
a result of the work coming out of the
museum reimagining initiative
which is likely to result in a
significant change to that project
particularly
there will be an opportunity then at
that time for the public to feedback on
any other elements of the annual plan
that they wish um council to consider
so the time frame that's outlined in
this report is based on if consultation
does take place if for some reason it is
not required
then we will try to deliver the annual
plan a little earlier
um
[Music]
and that's probably all i will say at
this point other than to note obviously
for this committee i have outlined the
three main risks
so perhaps i will actually go through
those since they are significant
we obviously are waiting to see what the
government will do around changing
legislation around three waters and the
local government act
at this point under the current
legislation we are required to undertake
an ltp amendment
in order to deliver a three waters
opt-in or opt-out decision
um so that will need to be carefully
managed if the government doesn't change
a legislation which they have indicated
they will
covert obviously may
impact
um on the financial reforecasting that's
probably likely to be more significant
for the financial side we do have a plan
in place which is also included in this
that will be an update of the ltp
consultation approach to deliver
undercoverd so we can continue
um and obviously we're just all aware of
the limitations at the moment in terms
of the number of auditors and just that
might be flow on impacts into the annual
plan process from other processes
thank you for that rihanna that's um a
very interesting summation can i just
open it up for members of the questions
you'd like to ask randon
um uh
yeah
he goes down he started saying i think
about the next annual plan but actually
this is really important that we we nail
this now because it's setting the
framework a wee bit for going forward
any questions foreign
oh sorry well i think we just need to
recognize that the the risks are out of
our control yeah so as long as we have
the resource available to adapt as soon
as we need to
then
it does put some pressure on so we just
we just need to recognize sitting on the
shelf later that's right that's right so
the available resource may be the fourth
risk
or the need for additional resource in
light of the other three
yeah
the the downstream impact would be that
it actually placed it will place us
under pressure
yeah
okay um so look we could just i think we
do need to note that as a group that it
isn't always plain sailing unfortunately
given those three big risks and
effectively the knock on fourth one
there and that you quite rightly have
identified as a consequence of either
either or all of one to three i suspect
it will be all of one to three
playing
um randall look again just from my point
uh
absolute agreement and please that
actually we are looking from the
perspective of the long-term plan
that is actually the key document from a
planning perspective that we've had
corporately
uh agreed we should be living with that
for three years so i understand the
basis on which that's done and i get
this been much more closely aligned so i
get that and i also reflect um
the the wisdom
but if you've got a good long-term plan
you should try and live with it unless
you really have to set an annual plan up
and go to consultation so i appreciate
there may be
points that go with that
um no other comments from people do i
have a person prepared to account for
prepared to
move the motion that we receive rounds
report thank you rangi thank you bex
i'll put the motion then if there's no
discussion on the motion there isn't
i'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
those against
it's carried thank you very much thank
you arianna appreciate the
all the papers that you've actually
bought
i'm up to item 12
which is the business enhancement
program
and this is just a a late request from
me and ross
we were planning the agenda
with michael just to give us a quick
update on where things are at please
thank you to you
through the chair
i'd like to just give a an update a wee
bit on uh what we're trying to do around
business enhancement with our technology
and our services so i'll go through that
and then i'll just give a quick update
on what's going on in our cyber security
site at the moment
so council staff are currently working
on a business enhancement program to
bring back to council
hoping to get back to you by the end of
the year
it's currently in draft that is focused
on the ability for us to connect
digitally both with our staff and with
our community
that's focused on service improvement
and risk mitigation
so it will take into account the
internal audit actions you've
seen today but also on ongoing ones
because it is continuous program of
internal order
but it will be focused on technology
change and significant process
improvement to the ends that i mentioned
before in relation to connecting staff
and community
i'll be looking as i said before have
this to you hopefully by the end of the
year um there are still a few things to
work through
but i wanted to be clear that we're not
this is not saying we're not working on
improvements and it's not saying we're
not working on our internal audit
actions we continue to work on those as
part of our bau program and you've
already seen that as part of the
internal audit program brought back to
you today
the other update i'd like to give you is
on cyber security um there's
prior to lockdown
thankfully we put in a new vpn
connection from that perspective or
network
that allowed us to have a bit more
security over our network as we went
into lockdown
that was
pretty much the week before that we went
live on that so there was a bit of risk
involved in that but i'm pleased to say
that it was a very successful outcome
and created more security for us from
that perspective
other improvements we're looking at as
part of that is just a whole password
process it's just good practice for us
to continue to review what we're doing
in that space make sure we are protected
and protecting anyone that's accessing
into there
we're also doing a review of our email
filtering and security
services that's probably the
the highest risk
area for um channels for
cyber security attacks to occur so we're
currently under doing a review of that
and we're sharing that with the
neighboring
councils so it's being done as a
collective across all councils
in the southern region so
that's quite uh
quite a good news story from our side
that we are starting to work quite
closely
in cyber security with the other local
council
thank you councillors thank you
michael appreciate that do you think you
have any questions for for um michael
honest vehicle update
there none
okay um we've got a short resolution
here that we um
received the google update from uh from
michael on business enhancement program
i'll move that from the cheer to have a
second to please
thank you ringy i'll put the motion
please all those in favor please say aye
those against
it's carrie thank you very much thank
you michael appreciate that it's good to
uh to keep that those issues in front of
us um thank you very much
right we're at that stage where we have
moved to the um
the amended
agenda as we've said which is bringing
out of um
public excluded the independent review
of electronic access
and uh for those of you that haven't
already they're in your papers obviously
under public included but we're going to
deal with those
now
um so oh andrew's already there well
done andrew thank you
i've invited andrew to address us uh he
he ran the cutter on this with the
reviewer
and andrew i'd invite you to to make
some opening comments please if that's
possible ah thank you miss chair look
i think
the starting point
in this review is to go back through the
history and understand why this review
is here and the purpose of it i think
it's important the chair reminds you of
this earlier on the role of the risk and
audit committee and it's important that
you
uh refresh yourself i suppose and
understand why these is here and the
basis on which it was asked for
so
the
risk of boring you all i'll take you
back through a little bit of
your charter the history the terms of
reference and why the report addresses
those matters and deals with those in a
comprehensive manner
so to begin with i mean obviously it
starts with the terms of reference why
is this matter here and realistically
it's here because within the risk and
assurance terms of reference in
particular
there is a a power that
this committee is to monitor existing
corporate policies and recommend new
corporate policies to prohibit unethical
questionable or illegal activities
and so that that's clearly called out as
one of the responsibilities of this
committee and when you look at the
circumstances that gave rise to this
review that is then reflected in the
terms of reference when the terms of
reference talk about
in particular this committee wishes to
understand that the systems and
processes set up to implement council's
output resolution are appropriate
understood and were followed with regard
to the et cetera et cetera
so so you can see the basis for the
power for this committee to request the
review uh the terms of reference
reflecting that and then the review been
requested now with respect to the terms
of reference and and it's useful because
uh the minutes of that meeting where
those terms of reference were discussed
that were approved again at this
meeting and so early on under agenda
item four you've got the terms of
reference you can see there was a robust
discussion at that time around what the
terms of reference were what was going
to be included what the purpose of the
review was and so again you've got the
committee
understanding its terms of reference
understanding its powers and requesting
a review to be conducted to ask a range
of questions that he considered were
appropriate for it to be to be able to
fulfill its function
so
that's the sort of formal and
strict background to the the basis on
which the review is undertaken and the
answers or the questions that review
tries to answer if you then go through
the review it does that in a very
methodical manner it addresses uh the
legislative obligations the council had
to consider in terms of the privacy act
and
lagoyama in terms of how it deals with
the emails or any other matters that
come within its possession it then deals
with the resolutions of the council as
it was requested to from april uh deals
with the way in which uh services are
provided within council and then reaches
some glute some conclusions and i think
um
[Music]
it's really
the second part of the terms of
reference which opens up the real
findings from the review and i'll repeat
them again just to uh the risk of boring
you
it's that the systems and processes were
understood and followed
so basically the the review makes a
finding that the system processes were
fine but raises some issues as to
whether or not they're fully understood
by everyone who is involved in their
application and how they were actually
applied in practice
and that is the real finding of this
review
the systems and processes are correct
and appropriate
but there might be uh some improvements
around clarity in terms of how those
systems and processes work in practice
and so you can see that in the end we've
gone through quite a robust process in
terms of the committee's powers why
these committees deal with dealing with
it the questions that were asked
to be considered and the answers that
were given
so on that basis i mean i can only you
know ask i
dealt with mr buchanan around providing
materials i can answer some questions
obviously i can't speak for him in terms
of
his actual findings i think to be fair
they speak for themselves although they
might be a little bit
meaty to get through um
but if you've got any or require any
further clarification happy to assist
all right thank you for that andrew
that's very helpful that actually we've
got the report that we asked for and
that's
within a scope that was well and truly
with inside the ambit of this committee
to deal with thank you for those opening
comments and indeed your your your your
high level comments about actually that
robert is is providing a very useful
report for us
to understand our systems and processes
at this point um i'd like to open it up
for questions
in some sense of of andrew
but also
comments at this stage i'm open to those
yes snobby um two things
once the initial one's a bit of a point
of order i guess
the mayor earlier today tried to
introduce a legal opinion that he's got
from kim ken patterson
to um
to this meeting
and i just need to clarify with the
mayor that the report that he's about to
table or attempt a table
is open for discussion because it says
clearly at the top private and
confidential
now we're in an open meeting now so i
need to know from the mayor that he's
authorizing us to discuss that report if
he's introduced to this meeting i don't
want to be caught up on that
so i appreciate if you asked me
well can i just ask one question first
um uh
andrew if i could of you um
i the email i received said this was the
substantive part of the feedback to uh
uh to mr buchanan
um i think i like confirmation that he
actually has seen that
are you aware of that um i haven't had
an opportunity to
check word for word but i've done a
quick scan of the document that was uh
received by mr buchanan which had a
subtly different title to it
than the one that's been distributed by
sir tim but my scan is that they're
very much verbatim
i can address
the question a bit more broadly if you
want this stage i mean it was received
by mr buchanan and he questioned and we
discussed whether or not he should one
receive it at all because effectively
was a legal opinion written for a third
party
but we clarified uh with sir tim's
lawyers that it was meant to be received
by him and
that any sort of legal uh
sensibilities confidentiality were
waived in providing it to mr buchanan
secondly the the major point that caused
um a discussion between myself and the
reviewer was that in essence it was an
attempt to change the scope
and to that extent
the document was deemed
in essence irrelevant for mr buchanan to
the extent that it went to
trying to amend the scope that had been
sent by this committee
and to the extent that it dealt with
matters that were within scope
they were taken into account and
considered in the formulation of his
review
there was then uh a further response
which i think is alluded to in in that
correspondence received from sir tim
which dealt with uh
matters within the scope of the review
again and some matters without but again
they were dealt with and come up in the
addendum to mr buchanan's report
um so
short answer yes i can confirm
from my quick scanning of the two
documents that the that that document
was received
subject to the the change to the parties
that it was addressed to
um but the content uh is has been
reviewed by mr buchanan
thank you so in effect um the the email
we received last night was with that
opinion has has in short not been taken
into account by mr buchanan as he has
completed his review
um so um i don't see any point in to the
extent that it's within scope because
it's it's being dealt with by mr
buchanan we have his report
um and
i'm not inclined to see that it is
relevant to our uh our direct discussion
today okay thank you for that
and so just just moving on a little bit
of
i've read the report that andrew refers
to as being meaty
you've been you've been kind to him i
think
every time she read it nobody
twice and it's hard work
very hard um but look there's a more
serious issue here and and it's i've sat
quite for some times on now's the
opportunity for me to to make some
statements about um what what's
transpired in this whole process
um
and comment on on the buchanan report
and so i've tried to analyze
what what happened in that whole
incident of
hacking the email if that's what's to be
called
and so for me i've looked at the
policies before the buchanan report and
and subsequently since
and so the question for me is does the
policy allow for monitoring of emails on
an icc site and clearly it does
and and that's not specific to them here
it could be specific to
a group manager
monitoring the emails that have been
done by staff member so that's not in
question so the answer is yes to that
would one expect a chief executive to
monitor the emails of an elected member
without due course and clearly my
expectation that would be no
and then the third and most critical
question is do we have due cause in this
case
um to be monitoring the chief exec
monitoring that the mayor's emails and
the answer that is clearly yes
and that's that's specified
initially in the 27th of april
meeting that we had
where if you go back to the minutes of
that meeting we had a discussion it was
quite clear the outcome that the chief
executive was empowered to provide me as
deputy mayor with the weekly schedule of
meetings that the mayor was attending
and secondly to also monitor um
some of them emails because what was
happening in that is that i was getting
a weekly schedule that said to me it
goes to the following meetings but
before i get the next one which is a
week later
things crop up so somebody usually comes
in and says we need to have a presented
thing and a good example was the mpi
meeting around the
um uh virus that was in the oysters and
the things now i didn't get a heads up
for me and so one of the things we
discussed at that 27 april meeting was
for claire or her staff to keep him an
eye on incoming emails
and so that i didn't miss out on some of
those meetings uh because it's important
that we have a presence so that's quite
unique to invercargill in the normal
circumstances that wouldn't occur and
the mayor would just
say to the deputy or somebody else like
i can't make this meeting or i'd like
you to be there as a support person for
me at this meeting you're
more knowledgeable on this matter but
that doesn't happen on invercargill and
so we're working around that
so the issue then becomes if you have a
staff member
or the chief executive um monitoring
emails
for the purposes of picking up incoming
invites for meetings
and you see something else that's of
concern
would we as councillors expect the chief
executive or staff member to ignore that
email so putting aside what the email
was actually about if you found that
something in there was being done
fraudulently not by the mayor but by
anybody
would you say well actually that's not
the reason i'm looking at these emails
i'll just put that aside and park it up
that staff member being a manager or
chief executive would be hung in court
at a later stage if they ignored it so
my view of all this is it was
appropriate for the chief executive to
bring forward that email and i know
that's caused a bit of angst with a
couple of our colleagues elected member
colleagues but the bottom line is
we as a cheers group had tried on
numerous occasions to encourage the man
not to one
make media statements that were
inaccurate and downright dishonest
and that's for the record and we've had
numerous occasions of that and we tried
to encourage him not to do that and his
response is he doesn't care less
and so if we get a signal that says
that um
there's another media release going out
then it's appropriate to erase it with
us because it wasn't just a matter of
the mayor having his right to say what
he wants to say there was an important
twist in this particular email
and the important twist was
that the mayor was actually breaching
the local government act the code of
conduct the employment relations act and
the chief executive's
personal contract because he was in that
statement making a statement about a
staff member and he said he was
humiliated by staff member well that's
inaccurate he wasn't humiliated by a
staff member and i've got evidence to
that as his partner has
staff members didn't throw out his
personal effects those personal effects
were taken from that classroom by myself
the mayor and the mayor's partner
and the mayor's partner had total
control i sat there for a whole day
doing this exile
and i could see the tension between tim
wanted to retain everything and his
partner wanted to have none of it
and so it was right
for the chief executive to give us an
advance notice given the history
of um
media statements that had said
criticism of staff now i don't care if
he calls me bruises in the paper that
just water off a duck's back i can live
with that but when he criticizes staff
as he did with the i.t support issue
where he claimed he hadn't had any when
in fact he had
and he criticizes the chief executive in
the process we have employment issues
and they are not just reputational
damage to us which i can live with with
the mayor's statements but it puts us at
risk of a personal agreement and it was
quite right for the chief executive to
raise that in my mind and if we face the
same thing again today i'd expect her to
do it in fact if she didn't for reasons
of the privacy act and tiptoeing around
that i would personally hold her
accountable so i just think it needs to
be said
that we have very unique situation in
the cable where we have a mayor
through his partner who doesn't give us
a no surprises
a policy which we've asked for and is
reflected in the charter which is good
behaviour
and so
we are tiptoeing around the issue we've
tried to ignore the statements we've
tried to get legal advice we've tried to
challenge them in meetings and we get
accused of bullying when we do that i
mean this just seems to be no result
resolution to this and so um we are
unique and while we have laws around
privacy and we have indoors around
leguma
we are not in the normal environment
here we have a very unique situation
that we're trying to manage
thank you navi i just would like to just
be careful here we're not we're not
we're not indeed as as
mr buchanan has been at pains to do in
his report
being clear that he was not engaged to
review
it's in our terms of reference the
events of the 10th of august
so i i'm going to receive those comments
uh nobby and the generalities of
actually how the system is working well
not just i just made them for one reason
chair
and that um
while i accept the terms of reference
and i and you'll acknowledge that the
mayor did not agree to those terms of
reference
and and counselor kit has recently made
a statement which is outrageous again
the public need to know that this
behavior is not acceptable this is not
going away with the buchanan report
we've already got this report here
um i'm already privy to the mayor
wanting to take this further so this
does not die today and this will have a
hit ahead of its own another head of
steam up so
just we just need to what i need to be
saying um
that we need to be ahead of some
someone's debate as well because it's
going to get messy thank you appreciate
your advice yes
um look my question is directly at the
report and it is chat uh not chapter um
paragraph 122 and um it it states um
the privacy act and it says accepting
that the mayor's email to the reporter
is personal information now i just want
some clarity on that because i want to
raise two points
now
the email
because it actually refers to the email
so we are talking about the email
because
it's personal now by the
nature of the language you used in the
email and i have that
email
copy that appeared in the in the odt
um is in the form of a press release
that would be made public so i'm just
wondering how
it can be personal if the end use is
going to be public and the second point
is that at the cheers meeting in
question
the mayor told us
that
he did not write the email
now if you did not write the email then
how i'm just trying to get my head
around how is it personal so these are
questions probably best answered through
the chair by andrew
uh through chair i think the the best
way to answer that is that look it's
it's uh when writing these reports it's
uh effectively a legal technique um mr
buchanan hasn't formed a view as to
whether or not it's personal or not uh
he has taken in essence the
[Music]
um
i want to use worse but it's not worse
but let's say let's put the email at its
highest standing and say it is private
what would be the consequences of that
and in the end he doesn't particularly
find any consequences so it's just a
writing and exploration technique rather
than a conclusion of a matter of law
so it's a hypothetical almost you could
have done the other hypothetical and
said if it wasn't uh personal what would
have occurred but it's just that because
the the deeming something to be personal
would have the highest consequence he
explores that scenario
there's no no legal conclusion he just
and that's why hence the starting with
the word accepting it's just i haven't
made a decision let's just accept that
because that submission's been made to
me so would he be aware that awards up
to interpretation of that particular
chapter that we all
just he just hasn't made a conclusion
because because he's explored the
as i said i don't want to use worst but
not because i i've explored the
circumstance that would give that email
the highest protection
and and and what what would be the
consequences if that were the case and
that's why it's appropriate because it
fits whilst we're
as you said it's talking in the specific
the review is in the general so let's
take the general scenario what's
acknowledges the collection of the
emails is appropriate but acknowledges
that they could be personal or not
personal but collection would still be
valid a use
what's the worst case if it's a personal
my my opinion of that then it is it is
quite misleading when you put it all in
context and you work it through it's
just about misleading that's all that's
from my layman's point of view
except that you could take it that way
but but understanding how these things
are written it's just a hypothetical
okay
thank you
um i think [ __ ] you may you might kinda
but um sir tim uh at the start of the
meeting you indicated you would like to
make some statements or raise some
questions that uh over the
uh report um i'd like to invite you if
at the stage you would like to make any
comments
yes are we in committee or no we're not
we're in public uh saturn
as we agreed oh as we agreed prior to
you came in that we would deal with this
matter in public
so tim i mean i'm
yeah
would you would you um like to discuss
with me what you want to say uh it may
be that you don't want to say it in
public
yeah um
i think i think it's pretty
i'll stop if i
think it's getting into dangerous ground
so
um
it's we have different interpretations
of
what actions have been said and
and it's
been
sort of
starting to degenerate into he said she
said
situation which never doesn't seem to
resolve things
but
i
have gone through a
large number of deputies
and it all follows the same pattern
they
um
seem to
be
yeah
that might be a bit critical i'll see
her
i've got broad shoulders to him get on
with it
the rest of us might not yeah
come on
let's have it out on the table but uh
um was the last soldier last surviving
open public
supporter of the mayor
and
i thought it was heroic
and went out to congratulate him through
the door saying
you know put on you for standing up for
your rights and
the usual rhetoric
and
he um
i said what why why did you change your
view so much and he said
oh they've threatened to
take my money that it'll cost so much
it's the same thing will happen to me
it's happening to you and
um so he was true he's not going to
pursue the matter now you'll see that as
a
great victory
but i don't i see it as
a bit of a tragedy really that
we can't speak without that overhanging
threat
um so i
just a few
minor points
wish to correct that i was not consulted
by the executive manager
about the role or required skills
for my part
as
for personal assistance
i feel vindicated by the report
buchanan has identified
the email with personal information
he identifies privacy principles should
there
therefore apply
the reviewer makes it clear
he cannot reach a conclusion
as to the
use of the
email after its intervention
so it's not so much what was said but
what was it used for
as the findings are inconclusive
i'm requesting a further review
with a broader scope
to consider the lawfulness of the
interceptions
as
as per my privacy
sourced opinion
i believe
there needs to be more precise review of
the specific event
of the interception
further i believe
the ce's admitted wrongdoing
should be
thoroughly investigated
and there needs to be representative
representatives
a repercussions i mean
the scope of the current review sort
to sweep the issue under the carpet by
focusing on arrangements in place
rather than the actions of the ce
and of course
you should have received pins
um
two tabled reports
so it's um
[Music]
i don't like to um sort of
spoil the party because
there's a lot of good work
been going on
here
and everyone's recognizing that
but
at the same time we've got to
make a stand for
the
running of um
the council along
lines of um
that encourage free speech you'll never
have total free speech because there's
so many regulations and we heard some of
them
but
we should always aspire
i believe
to encourage people to speak out freely
and openly
about how they feel
not just for parties and we should have
parties we used to have lots of parties
but um
we should also
i
think recognise that
there's a lot of
continual work
to
defend those privacy issues
and i
probably to the wrong side
my view of local government is
that
yes minister is a documentary
rather than a comedy show
and we should always be
all right celebrating success
but also
defending those rights that have been
fought for by previous generations
thank you
thank you sir tim nobby did you have a
response yeah yeah i do have actually um
yeah i'd be opposed to it
i'd be opposed to a further review um
there's cost involved with that and i'm
not sure that we actually got a really
good outcome for many elected members
from the buchanan report
um
when i look at the big picture here
contrary to advice that i gave to the
chief executive at the time she did
publicly apologize for
intercepting the email and not for
intercepting it by presenting it to the
cheers group she made a public public
apology for that
if the mayor feels that that's uh not
good enough he has options that don't
involve an external review and his
options are that collectively elected
members are the employer of the chief
executive
and he has a right as i said to peter
kitt yesterday
both of them have a right to raise with
us collectively
if they think that the chief executive
has breached the standards that we would
normally expect for her performance
that opens up a range of options if you
think about employment law from doing
nothing
through
a verbal warning a written warning a
final warning a summary dismissal
they're all options in employment law
but a report doesn't activate that
the report that we've got tells us about
the issues that we've got
and
the chief executive to her credit has
acknowledged that she
shouldn't pass it on that's not my
personal view i think i appreciate that
she did
but if we want to analyze and
identify whether that action was
appropriate given her apology
then the issue i think for the mayor is
he's ignoring that apology and is now
seeking for her to be
dealt with in a more formal manner and
that formal manner is an employment
issue
and therefore as her employer we have
options available to us which would
initially start with
the initial step in that would be the
mayor would put up his issue as would
peter kept
and the chief executive would be asked
to respond in writing and then we deal
with it
i want to reflect that's not the
business for this committee i understand
therefore through your committee the
mayor has introduced that yes no i
understand that and i appreciate your
advice not
because you're being patient sorry i
didn't go and
um
thanks chair um i've been thinking about
this and um you know the review it
appears has looked at what we've asked
for in the terms of reference
and in my recollection when we go back
to the time when we approved those terms
of reference and the person to undertake
that review
the mayor actually spoke against the
reviewer he didn't speak against or
ask for any changes to the terms of
reference
so you know i think that it's a bit late
to be kind of asking for that now
in light of the question which we
have asked
which
andrew pointed out earlier was
did we follow the systems and processes
that we had in place
and the answer to that appears to be yes
um although not all of us maybe
understand what that has meant for us um
in terms of access to our emails etc etc
so in light of that i'm wondering um
just looking at these recommendations
um for this uh report there's two
recommendations one about the learnings
one about receiving the report but given
the media profile of this and the
discussion of it in
so many public forums and so forth i
wonder if we actually need to include an
additional recommendation around
supporting that the ce's action actually
and sharing the email with the cheers
group was an appropriate thing to do
i would say that in regards to the fact
that the terms of reference for the
cheers group talks about keeping
counsellors informed of things and being
a conduit for information
i would also say that in light of the
first thompson report which we had
well and truly had by that time
which talked about helping council
to
support councillors and building their
public
building public confidence and you know
that's about looking after the council's
reputation
and also in light of the media protocols
which have been approved which actually
talk about having a no surprises
approach so to me all of those things
make it appropriate that that email was
shared with us and i would like to see
us include a resolution
in this
on this item around uh
acknowledging that the ce's actions and
sharing that email were appropriate
thank you bec so you are effectively
moving an amendment to this motion
yes
an amendment or an additional well in
addition i'm sorry
i've only got what i've only got two at
the moment so you're making the third
and effect um i don't i don't just try i
think probably this is one where i'd
like to treat this informally as an as a
an addition or an amendment to the
motion and i'd like i'd like to seek a
seconder
so if we just be clear you're wanting to
move what there's no emotion on the
table yet
oh okay sorry good point good point okay
okay we'll come back to that okay so you
can add it
well i suppose you're good at it yeah
fair enough um uh can we just
verbalize what you're trying to add to
the
move a
recommendation that states that the ce's
action and sharing the email um to the
cheers group was an appropriate action
for her to take
as per the findings of the report
or something to that effect
um that
clearly is quite right we just need to
get ourselves in the right place this
would be a recommendation to counsel
that they approve
this process
i think it's probably appropriate sorry
and darren thank you for calling me up
on process that i do actually get a
mover and a seconder for this motion so
you can see your second so x is moving
uh and knobby is seconding thank you for
that and thank you darren as i said for
correcting me
now is there any discussion on the
motion of the stance
yes
um i i don't have discussion i've still
got discussion pending
on what we're talking about before but
not regarding this particular
addition it was appropriate
things worthwhile just getting this
typed up thank you i know it's it's
under pressure but i think it's wise we
have it written if we're going to uh
consider the motion further are there
any other comments that would like to
raise thank you
is it we talking about the main item
uh you moved them all together haven't
we yep okay right look at you oh sorry
thank you mr chair at this point it
might be good if you clarify
i'm not usually a voting member of this
committee
on this particular issue
are we going by the original
extraordinary invitation that all
councillors
be present at risk and assurance for
this purpose
it is a recommendation to council chairs
so council will ultimately vote on it
anyway
uh yes i think that's the way i would i
would probably have needed more at least
in that actually
the chances for full voting is when it
comes to to council okay as such but i
am very happy for your importance at
this meeting if you would like to say
anything
yes i i'm going to restrain myself from
um dealing with the the entire report in
front of us but just refer to
paragraph 127 to 130 the concluding
comments and just point out that the
additional
recommendation that's gone up
um
is a useful
decision to recommend to council in
relation to paragraph 129
i think that clarifies
the reviewer has gone as far
in paragraph 129 as
his
invitation
terms of reference
allowed him i think it's very
appropriate that council adds
um recommendation three there because if
it can be seen as an extension of 129
and an actual decision by council that
it is an appropriate edition to make and
i agree
it's appropriate to
put that in in light of the entire
report which i will restrain myself from
going through i think um adding
recommendation three is very appropriate
thank you yes you do appreciate your
input in indeed as a voluntary member
here for your european systems boys i
appreciate it
are there any other points that folk
like make yes running um look at regards
a comment uh his worship made regarding
um the inhibition of free speech
and and um and so-called regulations uh
hindering that
now what i want to raise is that
obviously
um section 14.2 or section 14 of the
schedule 7
in reference
to council or councillors conduct and
elected members conduct
it has us at the start of the trinium
making a pledge that we will abide by
uh the exposed on us and that includes
the local government act now
and this is probably a question for
andrew can can a member choose if they
feel that they're inhibited by these act
denounce their pledge
and is that a possibility i just
wondered if is that something that
someone can go look i didn't know the
full implications of making this pledge
uh because it's restricting me uh i'm
wondering we were going here ranging um
it's a very interesting point and um i
might engage on it but i'm not certain
it's one that's quite relevant to the
topic we've got in the hand which is
okay
it was just something raised and i
thought well you know sometimes
you can yeah okay now if you wish me to
cease and desist i will thank you
appreciate that
right nobby just just one final comment
which is a similar sort of thing but not
the same um in the report in section 108
which is on page 126 of the board books
um
buchanan talks quite clearly about the
rights of people to speak on their own
behalf which is what demir is alluding
to and you know my position on free
speech i've been in trouble many times
in four council and a couple times since
then by being out of line
but it does clearly state there
that you cannot criticize staff publicly
that's a no-no and i've done that once
and i've worn the wrath of doing that
and secondly the accuracy the the
statements that you make on your own
behalf must also be accurate
and so while the mayor says we're
shackling free speech that's not the
case he's welcome to say what he likes
but it must be accurate and it must not
criticize that criticize me criticize
rangy that's fine
but the staff is no go so no go zone
thanks snobby
sorry sir sorry sir tim i've i've got
i've got alex i think you've you point
to making them
i just wanted to ask a question um and
that sir tim has referenced his uh legal
opinion from
ken patterson does that become publicly
discoverable form part of the report
it's not part of mr buchanan's report
what we have established
is that he was as far as we know given
andrei's indicated there was a change in
the title it is the same opinion that mr
buchanan has seen
and he has taken into account as he has
prepared his full response
so he was fully aware of the yes other
opinion at the time
um it's just quite concerning because
obviously even though it was sent at 11
38 last night before of course this
meeting at 8 30 start this morning and
with a request for us to read it somehow
in our sleep um
was fundamentally flawed in several ways
there's so many inaccuracies in
what he has been provided as fact
so i thought i was just
we have the benefit of mr buchanan's
consideration of that in response in the
report that we are we are considering
and obviously at the stage we do a
series of motions so tim you wanted to
make a point
just that it's it's a movie
in relation to what na'vi said this
it's a moving target when you try and
pin down what is free speech it's
changing all the time
and
just one example was and
i was arrested in the 60s for
distributing jelly beans at a council
meeting
and it was the
um
the
led by
the man who saved britain
he
moved on and became a councillor
and
the other reason
i'm always seemed to be inviting and
defending free speech and
that was
the
um
i want to say tim if i could just
interrupt here it's a bit like my advice
to rangi um
i think the the the some of the the
finer points of free speech along with
also the oath under the act are ones
that we we probably could debate with
some interest but i'm not certain that's
that it's
directly relevant to
um uh where we're at
at the moment uh so i wonder if we could
move on please are there any other
points that people would like to raise
yes ross
i think it's
the
substantive debate around this will be a
council
just to remind everyone that here we are
a risk
insurance committee and we are looking
at the risks
and
mitigating those and the pro and
ensuring that the correct processes are
in place to be followed
so
that's a first and foremost uh
role
um i support um bex and
the statements you made around the
recommendations from the thompson report
the media protocols
and
um
council is important to learn that the
way they conduct themselves in integrity
um should be paramount so you know think
before speaking um
would be very useful
rather than making
build informed comments outside
thank you ross good morning
let's see any further debate
well just uh
it was so keith park that i
accepted the jelly beans and during the
war
my father was in the fleeting room and
got killed
um
and
training
on training for um
korean war
and so it's a treasure principle
that may just seem
there's a time for a party
but it's time for
some
real
discussion
um
what's fear and right isn't it
thank you sir tim and i think that's
tied back up with indeed ross's good
advice that actually the second uh
recommendation is really important which
is that robert has said there are
learnings inside this report
and he is ref he is asking us to reflect
on those and that indeed the working
group
um
it was working groups i'm not seeing
which one it is but we'll pick this up
for consideration because we need to
deal with that so we are saying from our
systems and processes point dare i say
it from the
wider points that you're saying
and that are alluded to inside this
independent report that they do need to
be picked up and thought through as part
of the working group
so
i think that's a good place to leave it
if there's no more discussion
we have beck's moving all three motions
or resolutions and nobby i think i'm
correct in saying you have seconded
these sure
with that then i would like to put these
motions all those in favor please say i
those against
it's kerry
jubstein
you're abstaining okay sorry if we could
amend that please um to recognize tim's
abstention
from the vote please that would be
useful still past majority
okay thank you for that and um uh um for
dealing with that we are still in public
session
um and we indeed still have two matters
to deal with the first is urgent
business i haven't been informed of any
urgent business
and the last item which is the old item
14 is to
move into public
excluded and we have
the
items to be considered in public
excluded obviously
with the late
elimination of what was g which was the
independent review which we have just
considered in uh in public
so
i will move from the chair that for the
reasons that are stated in the table
we we move into public excluded do i
have a second to please
thank you ellen
i'll put the motion all those i'm sorry
michael can i just ask that phil fisher
and annabelle duncan are included in the
exceptions for the tax update please
please that's good we've got external
people from pwc to join us for the
tax governance policy uh item and so the
motion should include
theirs and also as i recognize i think
we've moved that jeff and lindsay by by
uh natural
role are also here as well
so i'll put that motion please all those
in favor please say aye aye aye those
against
it's carrick
can i recommend that we've done well uh
clear if it's like oh no can i just
signal that for item eight the mayor
will have to be absent yeah yes
thank you appreciate that and that's why
we will uh this is our practice take
that as the last item on the agenda
are we still on live stream
uh for the general blog
andrew will finish just a moment
no no no i'll certainly make sure
actually what i'd like to recommend is
we've gone well
you